[Music]
it's great to be here today with you
Dario it's great having a director of
safety with us in this case director of
safety of AI systems at open AI thanks
for joining us today and just give a
fabulous lecture and folks out there who
see this fireside chat who have not seen
your lecture yet this is a pointer into
the lecture well I thought remarkable is
internment in terms of similarity
between us is that we've had similar
pasts and it's talked a little bit about
how you got to where you are now it's an
interesting trajectory towards the world
of intelligence and it's their notion of
on to the safety and robustness but you
started out in physics and you talked a
bit about how that progressed to where
you are yeah so I mean I think you know
when when I was young you know I really
wanted to you know figure out who
universe works why don't wanted to be a
physicist wanted to drive drive
fundamental laws and then so I did my
undergrad in that and when I went to
grad school which was was also in
physics I got really interested in you
know what what what can kind of you know
both the methods and the recording
devices from physics tell us about
neuroscience and the brain and
intelligence and you know I thought of
kind of doing doing doing AI at that
time but I felt like you know I really
wanted to I would want to understand the
brain because like you know the the only
existing example of you know a truly
truly intelligent system so I spent a
fair amount of time doing that in in in
grad school did did kind of a postdoc in
in computational biology and then
through Stanford got to know about a
speech research project going on baidu
under under and doing so I was there
that I was at then I was at Google for a
year and then a little over a couple of
years ago I joined joined open AI and
some time around what I was working on
things that Baidu and and Google just
got a lot of experience with kind of the
the brittleness of neural nets how you
know in one sense they're very robust
and powerful but that when you go off
you know some given some given
distribution that they don't
they don't do so well and that you know
it you know it's it's hard to understand
really what's what's go what's going on
inside them and particularly that in the
long run is you know we make systems
more more powerful these these problems
are only gonna get worse so decided that
was when I wanted to work then but going
back I mean we'll come back to where you
are now in the great research that
you're doing with your team but going
back to this this decision or this deep
curiosity about what's going on in
brains and neurobiology what both what
was the spark of that yeah I mean you
know when I when I got to Princeton for
grad school there were a few
biophysicists there working on you know
like models of the models of neural
circuits based on statistical mechanics
and having done fair amount of
statistical mechanics as a physicist I
was I was really interested in you know
what what you know what what can we what
can we say with these kind of you know
statistical models that that are based
on thermodynamics about the brain can it
give us any insight you know just in in
vague terms like you know a lot of
people were kind of analyzing single
neurons saying here's a circuit this
neuron does this that neuron does this
maybe things are more about the
population and this distal properties
and that seemed very intuitive to me so
I kind of wanted to wanted to wanted to
devote myself to looking into it and do
you feel like in advance of your work in
AI you came away with any intuitions or
insights about what the heck's going on
in vertebrate brains yeah yeah it's it's
hard I mean I think one lesson I learned
about the field of neuroscience is that
it's very limited by our ability to
measure what's going on in the brain
theory is over determined you know it's
actually very very much like in particle
physics right where you can come up with
a whole bunch of theories but if you
only have a little bit of data then
there there are too many theories that
could fit that data so so in
neuroscience were all we're always kind
of trying to get to get more data and I
spent a lot of my PhD trying trying
trying to do that with you know at least
at least some some success although you
know much much much less than I would
have
would have would have hope for the you
know that I think the field needs to
really to really to really understand
things you know you know I did get some
instincts that you know things like you
know simple reinforcement learning
approaches may maybe in some ways on the
on the right track you know if you look
at you know if you look at hippocampus
you know there are things that look like
temporal difference policy updates
happening that look look surprisingly
surprisingly much like it so the idea
that that RL is a piece which you know
kind of really has ended up being being
right right in the field was like one of
the one of the lessons that I want to
lessons that I drew so it was great
reading about your earlier work and your
work you did during grad school in
neurobiology they went have fun to talk
to you over lunch just now where we
compared some notes in that at Microsoft
Research we have had a collaboration
with with Bill Christine's team at UCSD
taking the latest in ml tools machine
learning and visualization to try to
understand what's going on with sets of
neurons in this case him the medicinal
each and you working in the salamander
yeah so yeah I've done some work on
salamander retina and you know we were
really just kind of the logic there was
to try and you know understand you know
the nervous system of a complex animal
by taking a kind of separable piece of
it where you know the salamander retina
you can fully control what goes in goes
into the salamander retina and then look
at what goes up the optic nerve and so
you have this kind of sandbox that's an
isolated piece of the brain you can
control the inputs observe the outputs
and look at what's happening to every
every neuron in between and you know
what we focused on was trying to record
from a large number of these neurons and
saying what is the whole population of
neurons doing what is what is it what is
it coding for how does it collectively
communicate communicate information and
you know it got me thinking about these
kind of higher higher level questions
about about intelligence yeah I just
personally been been blown away by what
evolutionary biology discovered they
could do with cells
and tangles of cells to do cognition
whether it be invertebrates or
vertebrates to me I would I would
certainly have stuck with neurobiology
if I thought I could make better
progress now if you feel the same way or
not yeah I I kind of feel the same way I
mean we're very much limited by by data
you know that you know when we have a
very limited amount of data then you can
come up with all kinds of theories for
it and it's kind of over determined too
many of your theories fit the data so
we're always trying to collect more data
and what I wanted to make these kind of
theories and models but spent most of my
time you know improving the data and had
I think some success with that but you
know if I felt that we were really at
the point where you know we could report
recorded millions of neurons pour
through the data and try try and try and
try and analyze it and we knew the end
we knew the data was accurate and we
could correlate it to stimuli and human
behavior and the thoughts in humans head
then then we could kind of really have a
mature science of neuroscience and and
probably probably if that was the case
then that I would have stayed in the
field but I really felt we were limited
in in what we could do and what we could
record and that actually AI was
answering our questions in more
interesting ways so I think for people
like you and I a I is our neuroscience
right now yeah I would I would say so
moving into into you're working in it
jump into it to an AI company going from
a postdoc I guess it's a by do is gonna
just in your jump and how did that
happen exactly yeah so I mean very much
kind of just just as you just mentioned
you know I ended up picking up a fair
amount of ml along the way when we were
doing like spike signal sorting for the
neural arrays you know just just just as
you mentioned just the pure signal
processing tasks never even mind the
neuroscience you know he ends up using a
lot of machine learning and pattern
recognition and so I was you know I you
know I would say I was kind of like in
an amateur in the field but not someone
who didn't know know anything know
anything about it and then when I found
out about this this effort is by if I do
was to just just as it was getting
started you know I felt like I was
really it was really really an opportune
so you know I kind of went away and you
know studied studied you know
convolutional neural nets and recurrent
neural nets for you know for a while and
ended up getting getting hired and I
kind of kind of you know really enjoyed
it and never looked back in your work on
speech for the Leafs that you you were
able to push out what were some of the
techniques and insights that you were
that helped you out there and in terms
of getting those new results yeah so a
fair amount of it was just kind of pure
scale and engineering so I was more in
the m/l side but also kind of worked
with the you know the the systems folks
so I think one of the things that the
baidu lab was successful at was you know
using synchronous stochastic gradient
descent before other people did I think
you could describe what that means yeah
so so basically the standard the the way
you know when kind of the AI results
first started coming out of Google and
Toronto in 2012 the standard thing was a
synchronous gradient gradient descent so
this was done within Google very much
kind of like the web server model where
you know each machine has a batch and
each machine computes the gradients of
that batch and there's some central
server that you know that has the value
of all the parameters in ammeter server
yeah parameter server and the gradients
get applied and so this it's
asynchronous because I can be
calculating the gradients of one model
and apply it to some new model that's
been updated and in the meantime
synchronous gradient descent is more
like I have all these machines they
compute gradients they do a big all
reduce sum up all the gradients and
apply that gradient to everything so
like the whole set of machines takes one
big step and then one big step and then
one big step that turns out to have
benefits in terms of kind of
reproducibility and also seems to in
some contexts lead to better results do
you think part of that was just the
advancing computation at the time yeah
that's that's what about what I was
about to get to a lot of the stuff we
did in speech you know was was just our
ability to kind of scale things up use
more compute collect more data we even
kind of made these graphs of like how
much better do you
as a result of a number of parameters if
the architecture is right number of you
know like the the amount of amount of
data that you use and you see these very
smooth log-log plots that you know after
after I left by two they explored this
some more and it turned into this paper
called deep learning training is deep
learning scaling is predictable
empirically and that's been one thing
that shaped my my thinking that kind of
once you know once you once you have the
the paradigm for how to solve a
particular task right once you have all
the conceptual stuff right then the
scaling has these super smooth
properties to it you know it's clear
that there's been four you know number
of years now excitement exuberance about
the possibilities of breakthroughs in AI
also fears anxieties and these different
opinions on which way things might go
and whether there are deep concerns to
be grappled with or it's time to
celebrate immortality through through
the advent of powerful machinery that
could second we could jump into some day
from the 40s on people have captured the
attention of the public and some and
some technologists and some scientists
and I'm curious if that was the context
in which you started working in safety
what how did you get going on the yeah
so I think I think I was kind of you
know aware of some of the kind of more
more more extreme views in terms of in
terms of safety and you know in many
cases I thought people were it was true
kind of like jumping headed themselves
or you know not not thinking about the
the problem in the right way but at the
same time I thought that there was
really a kernel of important truth to
some some of what they were saying which
is that you know if you have a powerful
AI system and you know today we have
somewhat powerful AI systems but they're
getting more more and more powerful
every day that you know they and if that
system does has goals objectives that
are not aligned with the ones you want
them to be
that that that can lead to two accidents
two catastrophic to catastrophic
behavior you know my my perspective on
it the perspective that I you know that
I hope I've helped to kind of to bring
to the safety field is this empirical
perspective of let's look at let's look
at today's systems if you think of some
problem that you might might have in the
future or some safety issue that you
might have with future powerful AI
systems can you kind of build a replica
of that today and you know in today's
systems to study the problems
conceptually and build kind of durable
safety approaches so that if the AI
system gets more powerful the safety
approach gets more it gets powerful
powerful along with it and you know
someday we'll have we'll have super
intelligent machines and then I hope
that that that day that on that day
we've we've been spending many years
making the safety of systems systems
better and better and so it's it's a
problem that when we finally do face it
we do know how to grapple with it
I think it's it's um just reflect a bit
in real time there are different often
unstated intuitions about what the
concerns are notions of something might
go wrong and there's some costly outcome
but it's noticed and seen and yeah
people set a system down or they or they
address an issue and make a system
better does the idea of something big
happens and it's hard to ever stop it
and it's long term oppression of human
beings in or there's a third notion of
further many more of something is going
wrong very very under the hood and
implicitly it's having it's creating
some some nuances in the world that make
us unhappy as individuals or mix our
society it's costly to the society like
even how Automation might shift and
cause more in equity and wealth for
example and I'm curious which you know
sort of where do you think you the
concerns around what you're addressing
like all of the above two different
different degrees right so you know I
think I think there could be kind of
unitary problems where we build a
specific AI system where
we want it to do X and an instead does
why but that's noticed yeah and it's
it's noticed but but maybe something
catastrophic happens before before we we
notice it and we corrected but you know
but but damage was done I mean this is
the case in self-driving cars they have
problems people you know the crashes
eventually some people will die you know
already already have and then if we if
we if we increase the stakes to you know
systems that are making you know
important decisions for you know the the
economy the financial system humanity as
a whole these kind of discrete danger
certainly certainly can't happen at the
same time this kind of like diffusion
throughout the economy of kind of AI
systems like you know subtly changing
society in some way or changing the
economy or changing how humans relate to
to to each other in a way that's like
you know could be could be really bad
but that we don't notice right away I
mean I'm I'm very you know I think there
are opportunities for that as well of
course they're also opportunities for
you know for for AI to have positive
effects of that of that type you know to
you know help humans make make better
decisions to understand themselves
better to do to do to do all kinds of
things like that so I see both the
positive you know the positive and a
negative in the people you ought a few
years ago I think this was a you know
maybe your coming-out manuscript that
you were gonna be taking a serious look
at safety issues as a co-author you
mentioned you know five concrete you
know types problems you saw pick a few
admission talk about these so the one
that people ended up kind of a welcomed
liking the most was reward hacking so
it's this this idea that you know you're
trying to get an AI system to do
something complicated like you know some
some you know complicated some
complicated human activity like you know
you know like just just some I can't
think of an example off the top of my
head but you know you have some simple
simple proxy for I don't know example
would be like you know trying to help
humans connect to each other better or
something like that or make you
happier you have some simple proxies
that are usually correlated with it and
you start to optimize one of the proxies
and as you do more and more up
optimizing of the proxy it kind of
starts to diverge from the thing you're
ultimately trying to get right you know
you like a lot of a lot of a lot of tech
products it's really easy to measure
like engagement or clicks and you know
they were kind of used as a lazy proxy
for the users getting what they want and
the user is enriching themselves and
that's that's that's maybe true before
you optimize heavily for it but once you
optimize heavily for it that correlation
can break and so noting that this is a
general problem for reinforcement
learning systems and you know whatever
comes after reinforcement learning
systems are all plus plus it's a it's a
general feature of you know it's a
general feature of systems that are
throwing a lot of optimization power and
compute to pursue a unitary goal you
should have a really expressive video of
what one of your systems did when it
discovered how to had a hack a value
function or an objective I should say
more generally we could describe that
that game yeah yeah so it's this boat
race game I probably probably shown this
video a bunch a bunch of time people who
haven't seen that yeah I said it click
on that link they'll find it yeah so
it's like this boat is supposed to be
completing this boat race and you know
the way it's set up is you know I was
training this among you know hundreds
hundreds of other games so I didn't look
too closely at the reward function but
the way it's set up within the game is
you get points for you know hitting
these targets along the along the along
the course and then you know points for
finishing the race and so you would
think well that in 10 devices it's not
quite the same as saying finish the a
their race but you would think would
incentivize the agent to finish the race
but it turns out that their boat can
find this isolated Lagoon and basically
spin around in this perfectly designed
circle in order to keep getting these
power-ups just as they regenerate and it
can get such a high density of points
that it's like I don't even need to
finish the race I'm just gonna find this
lagoon and spin around in it forever
and it's certainly showing that video as
a way to you know you can save 30
minutes of a presentation and say look
at this video here's what happened with
these methods
and get to sort of push the point
through very clearly the other other of
these challenges to AI systems in the
open world include notions that I would
say are captured by the the classic
frame problem in AI yes talked about the
notion that I systems really didn't have
enough knowledge to understand the
current state the qualification problem
and when they took an action in the
world they really didn't understand the
ramifications given how much analogy we
need to understand all the possible
effects of action and I get the sense
that uh that could characterize a lot of
what we're seeing now in modern AI as we
work with these probabilistic systems
yeah no I think it's I think it's very
true I mean it's what I had in mind with
with some of the safety problems right
that the world is a really big place and
agents are agents brains are relatively
small humans brains are relatively small
there's much more in the world that can
ever can ever fit fit fit in your head
and also at least for our reinforcement
learning agents the reward functions are
even smaller and so you know there's no
way or gonna capture all the subtlety
right even even humans are not going to
understand the world they have a bunch
of heuristics they have a bunch of ways
to compress it but even then it's not
perfect and then if we're crippling
things further by by you know having
these these very kind of hacky proxies
for reward functions that just seems to
me like a recipe for things going wrong
and just reflect no I think you spent
time today during your distinguished
lecture talking about your current
direction which is to figure out it's
also very shared goal with Microsoft
research efforts in this in this realm
how do weave human intellect into the
process of designing and guiding these
systems stay a little bit more about how
that what sparked that whole direction
in your work yeah so you know I think
the you know the original work work on
that about
year-and-a-half ago now was you know
myself and one of the people in my group
Paul Paul Cristiano who'd been been
riding on one hand Paul had been writing
about things similar to this for a while
I got very excited about it from a
safety perspective and I think there's
you know also fairly rich academic
literature on you know putting humans
into the into the training loop but a
lot of it kind of hadn't caught up to
the power power power of RL systems and
hadn't been done for deep learning we
really didn't know if it was something
that worked at scale so you know we said
you know let's let's see if on modern
modern RL tasks and modern modern AI
systems we we can make this you know put
humans in the loop during training in
order to tell a AI systems what their
goals should be and what human values
they should embody and then a test time
the agents can act completely completely
autonomously this seemed like you know
are really a really appealing approach
because it means the ice isn't because
in the end act completely autonomously
but because it's interacted with humans
during training it kind of embodies a
picture of human human values and human
directives and goals and so you know we
spent a few months trying to get that to
work and you know found that for a lot
of the modern modern RL tasks we could
in fact get it to work and so a lot of
our work more recently has kind of
branched off that it seems that there
are several different approaches to that
um we've been a number of projects where
we try to characterize human intellect
characterize machine intellect
understand blind spots understand where
each agent does a great job and
understand how to do the handoffs or the
synthesis of these intellects and the
interesting work you just talked about
was about for example humans providing
hence feedback shaping of the utility of
the utility function and reinforcement
reward it seems there are several ways
to go in this front so I mean you yeah
what's what are some interesting
directions there yeah so you know as as
you mentioned the original paper was
kind of like you know agent gives some
examples of you know what it's it's
behave
to the human and asked you know which of
these are best what is more like what
you want me to do and you know it's in
the original paper it was like a binary
choice it was like you know it was left
better or the right better now we're
expanding in various directions thought
is you know can can the human give
feedback to the AI system in natural
language or can it give feedback kind of
more indirectly can one AI system help a
human understand how to train another AI
system so that's kind of a more more
complicated way of having humans and
existing ai's work together to train
more powerful ai's we're also kind of
you know thinking thinking of going
going in a more like language language
focused direction we're thinking of
combining it with other techniques a
common technique in reinforcement
learning is you know imitation learning
where human demonstrates a task a bunch
of times and an AI system looks at that
and tries to copy it or learn what the
human is doing so that's kind of another
way to get humans involved and I think
our general vision is like how do we cut
and let's work to try and find ways to
combine all of these features together
because it's a little how children learn
they learn by copying adults they learn
by getting feedback on whether what
they're doing is good or not sometimes
they just know the answer and they learn
from that and it's not really any one
thing it's a mix of all those things and
what are you some of your thoughts on
applying these methods someday to build
a system that has the the ethical
insights and wisdom that we might expect
from a sage we look up to when it comes
to hard decisions yeah I mean that's
that's kind of the ultimate ambition of
this sort of thing I mean obviously
there's a lot of things between between
what we can do now and and that just as
there's a lot of things between you know
between today's AI systems and AI
systems that are as good at humans at
everything but you know I think you know
we're trying to kind of gradually you
know scale-up introduce new methods make
dressed by pieces I think one feature
that'll be really important is in using
using humans to train AI systems you
know there are a number of biases that
humans have and a number of kind of
limitations in humans understanding
their own values and being able to
impart their own values so we're
actively looking for collaboration with
you know social social scientists
behavioral psychologists cognitive
scientists economists that those those
types of people to help us to design
those experiments right we think this
isn't purely a technical problem it has
kind of like a social science component
to it as well and we're hoping
increasingly as we move to harder tasks
to get social scientists more involved I
get the sense that you're an optimist
overall about where technology is going
is that true um I mean I think I think
I'm yeah I think I'm an optimist overall
in the sense that I think if we're
thoughtful about how to use how to use
you know technology it's you know that
that if we think really hard about it it
is possible to get to get a good outcome
you know at the same time it like it I I
hesitated a little because I think it
really it really depends on us and it
depends on how things are used right if
I look at the way kind of a lot of
social media stuff was was was rolled
out you know and just the the effects
its had on you know kind of kind of
democracy and elections over the last
few years like we didn't think any about
any of that stuff ahead of time and you
know as a result while these
technologies have had positive impacts
they've all day you know we're just
seeing we're starting to see their
negative side as well and so it's hard
to be kind of like us you know like like
like like a starry-eyed unmitigated
optimist and you know and when you see
that when you see that all around you
but the lesson I take from it is that
with with AI we shouldn't let that
happen
we should instead think about everything
we should think about the downsides
ahead of time we shouldn't have a
culture where we like you know where we
kind of attack people for thinking about
the downsides um it's like an important
function
I think is actually core to actually
getting the technically getting the
technology to work actually getting it
to deliver its benefits and that if we
if we don't have these thoughts and if
we don't have these conversations then
there's gonna be this backlash let's
push on optimism for a second what are
some just give me speculate with me if
yes 15 20 years from now what do we see
where are we with AI in terms of
applications theory yeah I mean I think
you know in terms of in terms of
applications I mean you know if they're
you know I you know you mentioned we
both we both kind of share this
background of having thought about you
know neuro neuro
no neurobiology and just kind of you
know the the structure of the brain and
the structure of biochemistry you really
get this sense looking at the problems
of biology that they're like beyond
human scale right you know you look at
these these charts of metabolism you
know every every you know every every
cell has don't remind me of human yeah
yeah you know every cell has 7,000
different you know kinds of proteins
that get expressed out of you know
30,000 or so genes and you know the some
proteins have one copy some have a
million copy some of them are like
phosphorylated some of them are and it's
it's just no human can remember it
there's all this data we're using
machine learning a little bit to kind of
like analyze pieces of the data but you
know it really it seems to me that you
know this is almost a problem Taylor
built for machines and so I'm I'm
hopeful and I've heard I've heard other
people you know even even the Microsoft
saying say same the same saying the same
thing and I think it's like a correct
optimistic vision I I really hope that
you know we can we can you know use use
AI to take over more of a scientific
process maybe all someday all of the
scientific process and you know cure you
know long what kind of long-standing
diseases like cancer that just have this
complexity that that we have a hard time
reckoning with similarly you know for
things like like like you know global
global warming or
or you know you know energy problems
just technology problems in general
which you know all you know all told
humans aren't really that great at so
it's twenty-five years from now yeah
something costly has happened that
people say that was a problem with AI
yeah what's your kind of best guess it
was what what had happened over that
period of time I mean there's lots of
like there's lots of kinds of things
that could go wrong I mean I think when
I think about kind of the the accident
stuff right there's there's the kind of
the most extreme scenario is you know
the world the world gets destroyed and I
think that's you know they're they're
scenarios were that that were that could
happen for instance via AI systems
managing nuclear weapons or something
like that if a country turned over its
you know National Defense to AI or
something like that and the AI kind of
wasn't wasn't wasn't wasn't well
designed in the sense that it didn't
even do what it was what it was what it
was you know what it was designed to do
systems that are supposed to kind of you
know manage manage the economy you know
if we really get to the point where
we're really putting the whole world's
trust in AI systems then I do think
they're extreme outcomes that that that
could happen on the less extreme side
just you know things like you know
problem economic economic crashes you
know systems systems being been unsafe
causing causing kind of kind of kind of
individual causing individual casualties
on the kind of like social misuse and
responsibility side you know I think the
invasiveness
of the potential invasiveness of AI
technology could have a lot of you know
a lot of lot of concerns related to you
know pervasive surveillance and things
like that just you know miss misuse
misuse of a of misuse of AI in general
by by by nation-states in changing
changing the world world balance of
power so so turning from from your your
thoughts about the future to maybe some
current questions if from some folks
watching this especially with regards to
career you've had such an illustrious
career even yeah
given how early you are in your career
going through many different phases of
interest following the natural terrain
of your curiosity I'm curious what your
advice might be to to focus thinking
about their major in college or with
their graduate work and beyond yeah so I
mean I think that you know ai ai and
machine learning you know are gonna
gonna continue to be you know you know
just just a big player in the general
advance of technology I mean even if we
stopped all kind of research advances
today just the pure applications would
be would be of what we already have
would be economically transformative and
I don't think that the research advances
are gonna get a ground gonna ground to a
to a standstill so you know I think it's
it's you know very promising career
direction you know I really encourage
people to you know think about the
social social implications you know it's
just number of like undergrads and young
people do seem to already be thinking
about that so seems like people are
thinking you know thinking thinking in
the right right direction I've just met
a lot of you know like a lot of people
who you know seem like they're they they
just genuinely care about you know both
advancing the technology and making sure
that it's it's it's good for the world
one one piece of advice I have is you
know I really think ml and AI are
becoming like much more kind of hands-on
fields and you know instead of instead
of waiting to kind of you know like take
grad school courses in them or that that
that that sort of thing that like just
like you know just like checking out
github repos for like all all the latest
models trying to implement them yourself
trying to tinker them with them yourself
I mean I think it started you know just
as kind of you know you know like
programming used to be academic computer
science and then you kind of move to you
know become more of a practical
discipline I think I think AI or many
parts of AI are much more moving to be
be this kind of practical discipline
that you know it's it's about your
ability to pattern match and so you know
you want you want to get cycles of
iteration in very
you want to implement lots of stuff you
want to know no models back and forth
you also need to know the theory but you
know like there's there's less of that
that it then then there used to be and a
lot of it is kind of starting to
consolidate well great
well it's fabulous talk to you today
thanks very much Dario thanks for having
me